DC Comics fans are up in arms
over a helmet in "Black Adam."
Here's why they just can't get over
what they call a major oversight.
Whether you hate "Black Adam,"
like the critics do, or love
Dwayne Johnson's biggest box office opening
as a leading man as the audience seems to,
it offers some hints about the
DC Extended Universe's future.
There's a lot of speculation about
developments in the movie and how
these elements might play in future
DCEU outings, like another movie with
Henry Cavill's Superman, as revealed in
the mid-credits scene of "Black Adam."
If you saw the movie, you know that Dr.
Fate died saving Hawkman from Sabbac,
leaving the fate of the Helmet of Fate at play.
The helmet goes to Hawkman, who uses its powerful
magic. Hawkman keeps Sabbac occupied long enough
for Black Adam to show up and save the day.
In doing so, he creates a decoy version of
himself and appears to fall when attacked by
the supervillain, showing fans how Dr.
Fate's vision has played out. However,
it turns out that fans are a bit
confused by this development. Here's why.
"Let me show you, my friend!"
Throughout "Black Adam," fans learn a few things
about the Helmet of Fate that gives Dr. Fate his
abilities and powers. One: it's "alien."
Two: only the worthy can even touch it,
as noted in a conversation aboard
the Justice Society's airship.
Lastly, putting it on exacts a toll on the
wearer, which gets exhausting. In fact,
what happens when the helmet "turns on" is that
the wearer is "possessed," as Dr. Fate explains.
This helmet has a long history in DC Comics lore.
Although the movie seems to be taking from that
lore, it's not staying completely accurate.
In the comics, the helmet is not an alien
object but an ancient one created by the Lords of
Order, who were present at the dawn of humanity.
It is truly a coveted object, turning its wearer
into one of the most powerful superheroes in DC
canon. And, as pointed out in the film, it has
some choice regarding who can wear it and when.
In the movie, the helmet's powers
include the ability to see into the
future and to project multiple images of
oneself, telekinesis, and invulnerability,
which are just a tiny fraction of the powers
the helmet bestows wearers in the comics.
Those abilities, in different DC properties,
have also included manipulating natural elements
like fire, air, water, and earth. In DC canon,
the helmet comes along with two other items:
the Amulet of Anubis and the Cloak of
Destiny, which also grant additional powers.
Given the long history of the helmet, fans
are definitely going to have opinions about
it. And in the case of "Black Adam," fans
are upset and perhaps a bit unsure about
a few things. The thing is, the
helmet doesn't necessarily just
turn on when the user wants it to —
at least, not when first taken up.
Nabu, the god in charge of the helmet, is still
a soul present within it. He must deem each user
worthy before granting the powers that come with
the helmet. This requires a period of judgment.
In fact, numerous people who wore the helmet have
found it difficult to bear the mental load. In
DC's New 52 world, Khalid Ben-Hassin suffered
bouts of insanity after donning it, but others
who couldn't handle the helmet were criminals
who stole it from their rightful wearers.
This means, of course, that the scene in which
Hawkman is deemed good enough to exact the
helmet's vengeance on Sabbac shouldn't actually
have happened as it did. On fan posted on Twitter,
"I just wanted to scream
'THAT'S NOT HOW THAT WORKS!'"
Another fan expressed confusion
about Hawkman not getting fatigued
after using the helmet and its magic.
Another was also confused and believed
the Helmet of Fate to be far too
powerful for just anyone to wear.
As with all DC history, though, canon has evolved,
and different interpretations of the character
have popped up in various projects, including
"Smallville" and a brief appearance in "Legends
of Tomorrow." The DCEU is changing things again,
which may inform the direction the
cinematic universe takes in the future.